okay everybody I'm so excited today
because I am joined by Isabella LeBlanc
and Anna lamb who star in True Detective
night country make sure you've watched
everything that has happened between
episodes one and three before you jump
in this interview how you guys doing
today good how are you doing good I'm so
excited to talk to you guys I'm
absolutely loving the show I love both
of your characters so there's so much
I'm just thinking about right now just
seeing you guys but uh Isabelle I want
to start with you in episode one Lee is
asking asking Liz about this mysterious
drunk driving incident so that's kind of
been a mystery looming over the show so
at this point for you as an actress were
you given a guide right at the start
that gives you all these answers about
things we don't know as the audience or
you kind of add of the looping points
like the audience is I knew I knew
Leah's story completely and Issa and I
had actually spent a lot of time talking
about you know the years of Leah's life
leading up to this moment too so I felt
like like I had a really full Leah
picture as far as like the other stuff
going on in the case I was a little in
the dark on oh that's interesting that's
exciting were you trying to like pick at
people to hear more things I was trying
to do the opposite because you know like
there's so much distance between Danvers
and Leah and it was already hard because
I liked jod so much and it was so easy
to get along with her that I was like
okay I have to try to build in a little
distance between us so I can't know too
much of what she's doing and what's
happening no that's totally smart as an
actress too I like that angle and Anna
after every episode I call my sister to
talk theories about each episode she
believes that Kayla is fishy and knows
more than she is letting on so for you
though is there a different type of
excitement playing a character that
people are literally breaking down like
every little mannerism and studying your
character
I mean it's it's been so fun to kind of
like as as the trailers come out and as
people get to see more to see like all
the fan theories that are popping up on
Twitter or on Reddit and I just kind of
like deep dive into them and I'm like
wow y'all are really invested this is so
cool I mean it's it's really exciting
and really fun and you know the
speculation is kind of all part of the
hype of the show and I love that we're
doing you know one episode a week
instead of dropping it all at once
because it just it leads to more
theories and for people to kind of put
their money wherever they want to put it
in terms of what happens yeah no and
it's challenging because it's type of
the show that's like been obsessed on my
mind thinking about it now so seeing you
in particular I'm like okay you're not
Kayla you're you're Anna um but
uh exactly uh Isabella there's like some
intense scenes we've already seen here
between you and jod and in particular
really stuck with me is the scene when
Lee is told to wash her face by Liz so
in these type of moments acting wise was
there anything you learned or picked up
on acting across like a legendary
actress in jod
Foster absolutely like I think I was
trying to do everything I could to like
not take for granted the moments that I
was having and to really try to soak up
as much as I could and I felt like you
know Jody's such a wealth of knowledge
and she also has like a very personal
and very unique process and so I felt
like I learned through her that you know
you just have to make space for whatever
you need you don't have to do any
certain thing there's no right way to
act and and so I felt like throughout
the process especially in those scenes
and and those more High emotion scenes
um yeah I felt more licensed to kind of
make my own space and and take the time
that I need to take and I felt like I
really learned that from jod oh that's
great that's great to hear that that was
like a big lesson you took from that too
and that you're able to still soaked
that in while you guys are doing great
performances uh now Anna that's
interesting is the relationship with
Kayla and Pete and I noticed she's like
a little off-put about him all the time
he's spending with li Liz Danvers and
being a cop but do you think she's more
upset about him all this time he's being
a cop or just amount of time he's with
that specific person in Liz
Danvers um I think it's definitely a mix
of both I know when we were discussing
with Issa like what our our marriage was
what our relationship was and who we
were as people it was kind of like a big
thing that prior being a cop was already
like one Rift in their relationship
early on um and I think it's also just
this feeling of like when you're two
young parents and you both you know you
talk about okay we're we're pregnant
we're keeping the child you know this is
a commitment on both ends how are we
going to do this it you really have to
like give and take and and and two
people work together to create the best
sort of environment for their child and
I think in this series Kayla one of the
big issues is her feeling of Abandonment
and and not feeling like prior's pulling
his weight because you know she doesn't
understand what's going on in in this
story in this case and and all the
different directions that prior is being
pulled in all she can really think about
is like I want to protect my family I
want the best for my son and um my
husband's not showing up what what's the
deal and yeah it's it's it was a a
really interesting Dynamic to play out
and kind of see through to the end yeah
and I love that detailed answer you gave
because now that's just going to have
people taking notes on every little
thing you're saying like is she giving a
little subliminal clue in her answer no
but that that's really great and it's
interesting too uh Isabella we see by
the end of episode three that Lee is
really embracing her Roots now and she
goes to this rally against the mine um
but I'm wondering just
psychologically what would you say is
the fear she is fighting against like
what thoughts is she breaking through in
herself to be able to do this yeah I
mean I think so much of Leah's Journey
feels really lonely to me like I I feel
like she's kind of a a solitary figure
and she has so many people she loves you
know Kayla's there for her there's like
there's you know so many people there
taking care of her but I think part of
her kind of feels like she you know
she's she's roughing the world on her
own and so I think so much of this
journey and so much of what she's
learning is that she actually has a
purpose bigger than herself in a
community that's bigger than herself and
the people she knows and and I think
she's actually finding some comfort and
some hope in that yeah and that's what I
love about the writing of the character
seeing that growth from the beginning
slowly and surely coming to bloom I I
really enjoy that um Anna so far I think
all the scenes we've seen with Kayla are
in interior shots so I was wondering do
you film these scenes at night as well
or do you actually get to experience
daytime working on this show oh no we we
shot uh the interior stuff during the
daytime but you know you're in there for
hours and you you have your snack and
then suddenly it's like all right lunch
break let's take you back to the
trailers and you walk outside and it's
like whoa like it's it's 12:00
already it's it's such like a Trippy
experience for you get to see I mean not
a ton not a ton of sun in Iceland
anyways so when you only get those like
short little bursts it's like oh okay
that's come and gone yeah and you were
originally from Canada right so are you
do you feel like you're used to the cold
like is this easy peasy for you yeah I
mean Iceland was perfectly fine for me
they have they call it the warm Winters
cold summers and where I'm from we have
the cold Winters and the cold summers so
I I was I was so fine with with the
environment and and it felt really like
familiar to me which was it was nice I
didn't feel too like out of my element
shooting in Iceland all right so people
are now goingon to write down that your
character was outside at some point so
everyone's gonna jot that down we
haven't seen it yet um now Isabella I
loved your post about a week ago on
Instagram about indigenous
representation growing and I'm talking
about the post where you shared the
poster of Kay and mentioning Gladstone
winning a Golden Globe so when did you
first start to feel you were getting
getting more opportunities or just scen
in general and Anna I'm going have the
same exact question for you right after
if you want to just follow
up yeah I feel like you know it's really
been in like the last couple years and
it it does feel amazing and I think what
I was kind of like going through when I
made that post is it like it feels
surreal to look back on like when I
first was going out to LA and when I was
doing my first auditions like as a
teenager like it just it did feel like a
completely different world and the work
felt completely different and the
characters I was getting to audition for
were very different and less interesting
and so it feels surreal and very
exciting to feel like even in like the
very recent past it has become like yeah
more commonplace to have Rich and
complex characters and a show where you
know there's not just one native woman
who has an interesting part but there's
a bunch of us and so we got to be on set
together we got to learn with each other
and from each other and so it just yeah
it feels amazing and very exciting
because it feels like you know just the
tip of the iceberg and we got we got a
lot more to bring and a lot more to come
absolutely Anna do you feel a similar
kind of Journey in your life yeah
absolutely I mean I've only been in the
industry for for a handful of years now
and and really the you know it's been
like an exponential change that we've
seen in sort of the the characters that
are written and and the stories that
we're telling and something that's been
on my mind a lot um is like the
sovereignty of stories and the
sovereignty of indigenous storytelling
and who's telling the stories and how
can we do like meaningful collaboration
and what is Meaningful
collaboration and you know being part of
projects like these with with you know
um indigenous producers and and you know
other projects that I've been a part of
in the past and kind of seeing this
growth and this change and um you know
it it makes me feel very optimistic for
the direction of indigenous film it
makes me feel very excited for this next
generation of indigenous actors to see
really complex and nuanced characters
and characters that they you know find
empathy and inspiration in so it's it's
a really incredible feeling to be part
of that change but also to look at
people like Izzy and Kaye and AA and and
and find that inspiration as well in
community and in kinship absolutely and
it's great to have this interview
opportunity with the two of you doing
this which is really cool and it's
exciting times because I I think about
just not just True Detective but I'm
watching like Eko what if um and Killers
the flower M you're saying it's like
this is really really cool to see and
exciting um so Props you guys you guys
are amazing and part of how great you
guys are in the show too um now Isabella
about a month ago I know I keep bring up
your Instagram I love your Instagram so
there you go but honored thank you
you posted behind the scenes of pet
cemetery I just want to know was that
chess you were playing on set and if so
what's your first
move it was
chess and I don't have a first move
because I'm horrible at
CH and I remember that Forest who I was
playing with he was my co-star in um pet
cemetery that he didn't even like
playing chess with me because
it was like even like enough competition
it was like but I I was just there for
The Vibes I liked the Vibes I was like
oh playing chess like on set that's fun
um yeah I I can do some more chess
training so I'll I'll Circle back I'll
move and good I'll Circle back please
unless you're hiding your knowledge from
us but that's okay too and a good actor
you yeah you're bluffing right now um
now now uh Anna you know it's really
exciting times for you too because
you're set a star in this Arctic comedy
series on Netflix so can we start
calling you the ice queen is there
something about you with these Arctic
Landscapes going on what's going on with
that I I I don't know I keep saying like
I you know spent three quarters of my
life being cold I'm ready for for a
little bit of change I want to do you
know a beach romcom but of course with
something as as exciting as as this
Netflix series which is like the the
first big budget comedy to be filmed in
the Arctic and and what's that what
that's going to do for for change and
you know infrastructure and kind of
building an industry in the Arctic that
we we we don't have um so it's it's a
really exciting time if you want to call
me ice queen feel free I'll take it um
but yeah very exciting exciting six
months ahead no for sure and exciting
six months ahead and then we have
exciting 3 we ahead for this show
everyone's excited to see how it's going
to end I'm so excited to see the fan
reaction seems like everyone's loving it
so far and you guys are just awesome in
it so thank you for joining me today
everybody continue watching Isabella and
Anna kill it in true detec night country
every Sunday on HBO and HBO Max I hope
you guys have a great day and I hope
talk to you in the future thank you so
much